surely you say you might be able to get
tape of Ronnie officiating this wedding
in Mexico I have a friend outside of
Ronnie that knows this couple I'm
working so what you're saying is you
would we don't need him so we're I'm
gonna get them myself so full of [ __ ]
that you have a car they Mouse your
breads there the shows from you know
some you have a guy I know I reached out
to me this morning yeah yeah I heard you
on the phone with them no I'll show you
the email house really your own show I
believe you
cuz you don't trust that Ronnie's really
gonna ask the couple for the tape he
doesn't know he's washed his hands of
this he's got out of the fire he's not a
real show no I don't forget Ronnie why
don't you want us to hear you
officiating a wedding because I want to
check with my friend from we're gonna
check I'll check with him
you're not gonna check behind every
three seconds who is it it's the person
that was tagged in the pictures that are
online and available for people do I'm
not gonna say their names on picture
step pictures okay I don't know well so
you figured it'd go right after tag then
their name is there yeah it's a computer
leave me alone I didn't know to my idiot
just proved that he figured it out yeah
obviously she did but I didn't know that
I don't look at Instagram I don't care
about Instagram well you might want to
start with discovered five